[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat
une aire d'accueil de grand passage pour
les gens du voyage doit voir le jour
dans le sud des yvelines mais dans
quelle commune
c'est bien la question qui inquiète
depuis plusieurs années élus et
agriculteurs autour de rambouillet c'est
en effet là que la préfecture a
identifié des terrains pouvant
accueillir un grand nombre de caravanes
les communes de saint martin de brut en
cours les essarts le roi ou encore
poigny la forêt serait sur la liste du
préfet construire une aire de grand
passage n'a rien d'anodin il s'agit de
recevoir des cortèges de 150 à 200
caravanes
pendant tout un mois quelles contraintes
pour les élus les terrains sont ils
adaptés pour recevoir les familles enfin
quel coût pour les collectivités avec
nous pour en débattre ce soir henri
braun vous êtes avocat au barreau de
paris milo delage vous êtes président de
l'association france liberté voyages et
membre de la commission nationale
consultative des gens du voyage et david
j'utilise vous êtes élu écologiste de
rambouillet territoire l'agglomération
bonsoir messieurs me sure je commence
avec vous david jutier c'est un dossier
qui ne date pas d'hier
alors maintenant il faut trouver un
consensus la loi l'obligent où en sont
les discussions entre les communes et la
préfecture est ce que vous en savez un
peu plus que nous vous avez cité les
trois communes qui étaient sur la liste
du préfet et qui ont successivement été
mise sur la sur la table moi je suis ici
avant tout pour vous expliquer pourquoi
nous élus habitants du sud yvelines
considérons ces trois propositions comme
totalement inadapté pour une heure de
grand passage
c'étaient les essarts le roi saint
martin de ré est en cours a
effectivement un terrain militaire sur
la commune de poignées en limite de de
rambouillet je suis là également pour me
faire la voix des agriculteurs et des
élus qu'ils ressentent une exaspération
à ce que ce dossier traîne et que
pendant ce temps très régulièrement on a
des installations de
deux groupes de gens du voyage qui y
pénètre dans les champs sur les
infrastructures licite en fait qu'ils
sont illicites
et la réponse qui est souvent faite
lorsque l'on va à la rencontre de ces
personnes vont systématiquement lorsque
des groupes importants se sont installés
sur rambouillet je suis allé à leur
rencontre discuter voir quels étaient
les les contraintes qui étaient les
leurs et comment nous on pourrait
avancer et systématiquement on me revoir
oui mais il ya pas d aire de grand
passage dans le sud yvelines et moi ce
que je la vois que je veux porter
aujourd'hui c'est celle de toutes celles
et tous ceux qui considèrent que le sud
yvelines n'est pas une zone adaptée à
l'implantation d'une aire de grand
passage
alors justement petite précision milo
delage qu'est ce qu'une aire de grand
passage c'est vrai que les aires
d'accueil traditionnels sont être plus
connu du grand public mais une aire de
grand passage c'est il ya une
spécificité 1
expliquez-nous et une aire de grand
passage c'est une ère qui peut recevoir
de 50 à 200 caravanes ça allait pas
ouvert en permanence mais doit être
disponible en fonction du besoin
c'est ça une aire de grand passage qui
doit être aménagé avec l'eau
l'électricité les toilettes et le
ramassage des poubelles tout ça aux
frais à la charge des occupants du
terrain il ya beaucoup de départements
qui sont en règle à nous on a la chance
de voyager je fais pratiquement tout le
territoire français comme les aires de
grand passage sans réalisée il ya plus
de problème de stationnement
s'il ya un problème le préfet peut
résoudre si vous gérez il a la
possibilité de faire expulser des
familles lieux qui sont restés installés
illégalement mais tant que votre
département sera dans cette situation
vous serez toujours confronté à ça ça va
vite en plus que millénaire de grand
passage qu'il ya des familles qui vont
vous des groupes qui vont s'installer
sur les stades ou sur les bases de
loisirs
parce qu'ils n'auront pas de terrain
pour les accueillir les pas de solution
il faut bien trouver une solution de
stationnement
je rappelle que tous ces familles c'est
tous des familles de francs française
s'est pas d'absolu
on en reparlera juste après ceux de
henry brawn vous qui êtes avocat
rappelez-nous un point juridique donc
les départements doivent alors j'allais
les aires de grand passage ce qu'il faut
savoir de la loi ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que depuis la loi qui a été votée
tout récemment 2010 est d'allouer à
égalité citoyenneté les aires de grands
passages sont reconnus au plan
législatif et il ya une obligation qui
pèsent sur les communes de mettre en
place des aires d'accueil classique des
aires de grand passage ainsi que des
terrains familiaux et cette loi a pour
la première fois mis en place manière un
peu timide des mécanismes de sanction de
conversion qui permettent au préfet de
bloquer l'argent et de faire en sorte
que ces aides soient réalisés alors je
sais pas ce que ça va donner
je sais pas ce que ça va faire mais il
est certain qu'ils à un progrès et pour
répondre aux inquiétudes de l'élu local
je ne vois pas pourquoi le sud yvelines
ce ne pourrait pas que les aires de
grand passage comme n'importe quel
importe où ailleurs sur le territoire
français je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes qui ne sont pas fondées il
faut voir à contrer les sauces d'un
point de vue positif et se demander
quelles seront les retombées économiques
désormais impatient je vous dis des
consommateurs pour la vie locale déjà
des gens qui travaillent qui sont pour
la plupart
commerçants sur les marchés ou artisans
dans le domaine du bâtiment notamment
qui exercent toutes une série de métiers
donc on a des professionnels qui peut
répondre à une demande et on a ensuite
des consommateurs des gens qui voient
dans les cafés des gens qui ont fait
leurs courses
donc on a quelques des retombées tant
que doivent être que positive pour
l'économie locale dans le sud comme
ailleurs
quels sont exactement une réédition de
moi je défends le ce que nous contestons
ce que je trouve particulièrement
surprenant c'est que pour la préfecture
pour les services de l'état jusqu'à
présent le sud yvelines se limitait aux
cantons de rambouillet st-arnaud qui est
une zone qui est extrêmement peu dense
et si on va voir dans la loi la loi
besson parce qu'effectivement la loi
égalité citoyenneté a apporté des
améliorations et moi j'en suis très
heureux en revanche ce que je
contest c'est que la loi besson liste
trois critères au regard desquels on
peut implanter une aire de grand passage
en tout cas qui permet de penser qu'une
zone est favorable à l'implantation
d'une aire de grand passage c'est la
proximité des des soins la possibilité
scolarisation des enfants
et effectivement la possibilité
d'accéder à des activités économiques ou
commerciales et je vous invite si vous
n'avez pas faim mais je suppose que vous
l'avez fait à aller consulter les cartes
qui listent ces trois critères qui map
ces trois critères sur les sur les
yvelines et vous voyez que sur les
cartes les zones denses en soins en
accès aux possibilités de scolarisation
pour les enfants et en structures
économiques et commerciales elles sont
concentrées sur le nord des yvelines il
ya une aire de grand passage qui est
dans les tuyaux pour triel-sur-seine
donc de ce côté là pas de souci pour le
pour le nord et puis sur saint quentin
en yvelines et sur versailles est ce que
moi je souhaite c'est que désormais les
services de l'état étudie la possibilité
d'implanter une aire de grand passage
sur ces zones urbaines plus dense qui
correspondent beaucoup mieux aux
critères qui sont listées dans la loi
elle même la loi besson de 2000
puisqu'on n'a pas attendu la loi
heureusement l'égalité citoyenneté pour
se préoccuper de l' équilibre entre la
liberté de circulation la liberté de
pratiquer la tradition d'une manif qui
est celle de nombreuses personnes de
notre pays qui comme vous le rappeliez
sont françaises et doit bénéficier de la
liberté de circulation
et puis d'un autre côté les
préoccupations légitimes des
agriculteurs des maires a disposé et de
leurs structures et à travailler dans
leur champ puisque un agriculteur qui
voit son champ occupé par un groupe pour
lui c'est une perte économique énorme en
plus de la contrariété morale qui le dit
c'est vrai que le préfet attend des
propositions de la part des élus de
versailles sur des terrains potentiels
mais on espère que ça va avancer sur ce
sujet et celle de saint quentin en
yvelines j'espère réfléchissent
également à la question
d'accord mais l'autre là je vous
comprenez
une réticence un des 1 des mers des du
village de saint martin de brett en
cours dit comment un village de 650
habitants peut-il accueillir 1000 gens
du voyage qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
répondre à cette préoccupation
si les aires de grand passage et si sa
commune c'est pas un problème vraiment
parce que si vous en passage c'est
parfaitement organisée vous avez des
responsables identifiables il ya une
charte d'accueil qui est signé avec une
caution à constat des lieux à l'arrivée
un constat des lieux au départ dans un
temps limité dans le temps mais c'est de
15 jours à trois semaines maximum
donc on est comme tout citoyen on tient
à respecter les règles mais à condition
naturellement que déjà les élus soyez
exemplaires qu'ils aient respecté leurs
obligations et notre problème à nous ça
date pas d'hier mais on vient d'avoir
l'abrogation du livret de circulation
que ça faisait quand même depuis 1912
qu'on était en position d'aller vers une
supposition que nous oblige et ça c'est
des choses qui sont graves
moi je dis qu'en tant que citoyen
français et fier des français comme tous
les élus doivent être exemplaires
vous devez respecter les lois de la
république sinon à quoi que ça sert
d'être élu de la république paie pour la
république monsieur de l'âge de taqa a
précisé que dans le sud yvelines
nous faisons montre d'exemplarité en
termes d aires d'accueil
nous avons trois aires d'accueil qui
fonctionne parfaitement on en a une sur
embrouiller une source interne ou aux
essarts-le-roi qui remplissent
parfaitement leur fonction et ce qui est
très important qui sont parfaitement
dimensionné avec notre territoire qui
est un territoire rural avec une ville
centre qui la plus grosse et rambouillet
qui fait vingt-cinq mille habitants et
c'est ce ce décalage entre une aire de
grand passage et le type de territoire
sur lequel nous vivons qui nous semble
poser problème
alors que juste au dessus nous avons des
zones urbaines qui sont finalement
identifié dans la loi besson d'après les
critères de la loi besson comme étant
tout à fait capable d'accueillir des
gens du voyage depuis monsieur de juste
une précision
il ya également cet aspect financier que
vous soulevez effectivement il y a un
droit de passage il y a
une caution versée il ya des garanties
financières qui sont apportées mais le
coût de fonctionnement de l'air de grand
passage qu'ils allaient occuper un mois
dans l'année
elle est supportée par l'ensemble de la
collectivité alors donc certaines choses
quand on parle de quoi parle-t-on j'ai
vu dans un verre toulouse une donc une
ère avait coûté 800 mille euros pour
construire une aire de grand passage on
est dans quel budget à peu près ça nous
remet à l'endroit qu'ils choisissent
avoir un terrain en herbe et stable qui
choisissent en par exemple j'ai beau
site et la ciotat
il avait choisi de faire une aire de
grand passage où il ya une montagne donc
à les abattre la montagne tout faire de
grand passage
donc ils ont attendu deux ans ils n'ont
pas fait c'était celle ci réalise alors
on a ce problème là aussi il ya des
projets qui s'en fait ou alors par
exemple une zone marécageuse qu'il faut
remplir et pendant pendant les 4 ha
parce que bien souvent roccat hectares
pour une aire de grand passage riz donc
ça c'est de celà servian 4 est donc
maintenant alors ce qui est important
parce que tout cet après midi j'étais la
commission nationale justement pour
justement qu'il yad'énormes par rapport
à la création des aires de grand passage
ça va passer par un décret d'application
plus le passé au conseil d'état
ça sera voté courant mars les donc on
aura pu proposer des terrains que
j'appelle moi à libye parce qu'on est
des fois confronté à ça il ya des mères
ou des élus cliquant qui disent on va
faire on a un terrain pour vous
accueillir alors il propose un terrain
c'est un vieux champ de labour terrain
impraticable pour monter caravane dessus
mais comme le préfet a validé des fois
sans voir ses terres de gros passages
entre guillemets on est expulsable sur
les autres terrains qu'on veut
s'installer mais on peut passer les
suces étaient à l'arrêt donc maintenant
la grande avancée mais c'est ça aussi il
ya des normes pour les terrains
familiaux les aires d'accueil et les
aires de grand passage et ça j'espère
que vous serez
respecterait c'est donc bien sûr sinon
vous serez encore dans l'inégalité si le
mot pause des terrains qui sont
impraticables
s'il ya besoin d'un terrain de 4 ha si
vous en faites un de 1500 2000 état de
deux hectares excusez moi donc ça
commence à sera pas suffisant
correspondrait pas aux besoins vous ai
bien compris qu'on relativement henri
braun à un mot sur aujourd'hui est ce
que au niveau des pourcentages des aires
d'accueil des aires de grand passage est
ce que les communes globalement en
france traitement les aires d'accueil ce
temps s'améliore on est là présentement
onglet à 60 ou 70% du papier sur le
papier où est réalisé ce que pas
beaucoup quand même parce que les aires
d'accueil ça existe depuis la première
loi besson de 1990 donc ça fait 27 ans
on n'arrive même pas aux deux tiers et
encore il faut voir comment c'est fait
en pratique pour les aires d'accueil
pour les aires de grand passage les pas
de chiffres on est quand même très loin
du compte
il ya comme un souci qui se posent quand
on parle d'accueil des gens du voyage
c'est d'ailleurs le titre de loi besson
pourquoi accueillir on n'accueille pas
on a des gens qui sont chez eux
comme tout même ce pays donc l'idée
d'accueil c'est l'idée qui aurait une
charge pour la collectivité et de pense
que c'est une mauvaise façon de voir les
choses
s'il faut bien comprendre là je ne
connais pas en détail les cartes du
sud-yvelines là vous en savez plus que
moi
bon ce qui me paraît évident c'est que
pour avoir un terrain de 4 hectares il
faut que soit une zone qui ne soit pas
trop peuplée ça ne sera pas dans une
zone urbaine qu'on pourra dégager un
terrain de quatre hectares ne serait ce
qu'en raison du coût du foncier alors
sans doute industriels oui alors ça y'a
pas de pollution ce qu'est ce que ça
fait 100 mètres sur 400 m quand proches
de zones urbaines
il faut regarder en détail je pense que
ce sont des sujets complexes bon format
simple la même salle il est intéressant
mais met en marche de versailles on peut
parfaitement retrouvé on marche de 5 en
amont ahronot pollution parce que
beaucoup d'aires d'accueil sont à
proximité de déchetterie ou d' usine
polluante c'est donc ça deux stations
d'épuration
donc ça et ça vous verrez ça dans
énormément de villes de france
le petit panneau station d'épuration et
le panneau aire d'accueil des gens du
voyage qui sont côte à côte ça ça pose
un problème notamment quand on accueille
des enfants sur césaire dont je pense
qu'il faut véritablement après le coup
n'est pas très important on me dit 820
euros 800 du lot on a quand même de
l'aude la joue une agglomération dès à
présent non non non on rentre on
implante de logements en france on a des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
sont sdf on a des millions de personnes
qui sont mal logés qui venant des
logements insalubres tout ça coûterait
une fortune
il ya une étude ya quelques années qui
avait chiffré à 30 milliards le coût
nécessaire pour que tout le monde dans
ce pays soit bien logés on a estimé que
c'était trop cher on année 300 milliards
aux banques un petit peu après peu
importe ce que je veux dire c'est que la
caravane est ce une solution
une des solutions possibles au problème
du logement je pense qu'il faut dans une
optique également une optique écologique
ce qui peut intéresser
monsieur cloutier se poser la question
des modes d'habitat alternatif que sont
la caravane où la lourde ce pas pratiqué
par les mêmes personnes mais je pense
que là on doit pas de relation dans la
caravane
elle est avant tout un habitat
traditionnel qui permet un mode de vie
nomade comme le vivent un certain nombre
de populations
c'est avant tout c'est pas une réponse
est peut être une solution une solution
s'est étendu à d'autres personnes vous
parlez des aires d'accueil moi je veux
revenir comme sur les aires d'accueil
je voulais dit nous sommes exemplaires
dans le sud yvelines
et c'est par noro la japonaise non plus
appliqué la loi ce qui est bien mais
c'est le minimum c'est parce c'est pas
ça être exemplaire si absolument parce
que dès que la loi était a été mise en
oeuvre
nous avons fait tout ce qui était
nécessaire alors que vous le dites vous
même certains autres territoires ont un
peu traîné ça vous dérange les
dignitaires du grand passage en quoi ça
vous dérange
je vous dit les agriculteurs cela pose
problème qu'on s'installe dans leur
chance co2 contre 9,1 mais glantz n'y
aura évidemment nous regardons tout à
fait 20 mois quand ces paparazzi de
l'homme quand il y aura assez de place
pour les caravanes plaît comprenez bien
que les gens les voyageurs n'auront plus
à sa stèle gars disent les agresseurs a
précisé que les autres ans ils ont été
proposés c'est un terrain militaire
actuellement propriété de l'armée en
limite de zone natura 2000 dans un
massif de protection avec les plus
grandes difficultés possibles à aménager
les sanitaires à aménager l'eau courante
l'électricité non c'est pas bien du tout
en plus c'est en limite d'une route
extrêmement extrêmement passante avec
les plus grandes difficultés aussi
aménagé à sécuriser l'endroit
premièrement donc ça avec des décibels
très important des disciples voix sion
en plus un problème mental et sur un
problème d' usage par par l'armée il
peut y avoir effectivement des travaux
là de dépollution de déminage je sais
pas exactement sur saint-martin-de-ré de
brett en cours et sur les essarts le roi
ce sont des terres agricoles
moi ce que je veux dire avec force c'est
que un champ ce n'est pas un espace vide
dont on peut faire n'importe quoi on
peut on peut pas se dire parce que là il
ya un champ on a une structure aménagée
et bien mettons là dans le champ nom un
champ c'est à la fois un
un système économique qui permet à un
agriculteur de vivre de produire de
produire l'alimentation qui nous fait
vivre toutes et tous
et puis c'est aussi une partie de
l'écosystème c'est une partie de nos
paysages et donc les deux autres
terrains en plus du terrain militaire
qui sont proposés ce sont des terrains
qui ont une vocation agricole ils ont
une valeur économique etc
c'est ça qui est extrêmement important
et puis il ya un problème en particulier
sur saint-martin nouvelle en cours qui
était la dernière proposition forte en
tout cas celle qui tenait la corde au
niveau de la préfecture
il ya un problème d'accès les routes les
petites voix vicinal un vrai gars sont
voilà là c'était on est typiquement dans
cette configuration la note aux un
terrain mais on pense à l'aménager voyez
donc j'espère que vous avez peut-être
des solutions dans votre thé noter
qu'elle sera la solution doc c'est donc
ce que j'ai industrielle soit dans un
champ vide est la solution pour moi elle
est d'explorer l'ensemble des
territoires du souligne jean est pas le
sud sud yvelines
est ce que c'est la responsabilité des
élus locaux
que dalle et je pense me la faire ce
travail exploratoire non c'est celle de
l'état avant tout la mise en lumière des
responsabilités en la matière à l'est de
l'état
nous nous sommes capables d'assumer le
fonctionnement des structures c'est ce
que nous faisons et c'est ce que nous
ferons un autre point monsieur de l'âge
si jamais il était décidé que les aires
de grand passage doit être installé dans
une zone beaucoup plus favorable saint
quentin en yvelines versailles grand
parc
dans ce cas là on peut parfaitement
imaginer moi j'y serais tout à fait
ouvert une péréquation financière
puisque effectivement là les coûts de
fonctionnement devraient dans ce cas-là
être supporté par l'ensemble de la zone
qui est prévue au schéma au schéma
départemental
on peut parfaitement imaginer au prorata
je me suis fait remarquer là
les investissements initiaux vont être
subventionné en partie par l'état
la partie frontale que vint y avoir mais
c'est pas c'est pas le sait pas de souci
moi je suis là aussi pour vous dire que
vous avez dans le sud des yvelines des
élus qui sont des élus de bonne volonté
qui étudie chaque proposition et si
aujourd'hui nous sommes opposés très
fortement aux propositions qui nous ont
été faites dans le sud yvelines c'est
que nous avons des bonnes raisons et
c'est pas des a priori simplement parce
qu'on voudrait pas par principe d'une
aire de grand passage dans le sol comme
le nôtre il était là en tant que ça que
j'essaie de vous rassurer sur ce point
parce que si vous voulez on a confronté
ça danse ça depuis toujours
voyez donc je veux discuter avec les
élus vous disiez que vous êtes en
discussions constantes ça c'est ça s'est
très bien passé ailleurs en france vous
allez mon association existe depuis dix
ans monsieur henri braun le connais très
bien parce que j'ai déjà fait intervenir
pas justement à des élus qui faisait des
abus de pouvoir
alors on avait pris une disposition ce
que dès qu'on arrive sur une commune ont
fait constater les lieux ont fait
constater les lieux à l'arrivée au
départ et en donnant des attestations de
bonne conduite alors sujets à peu près
pas loin de 400 attestation de bonne
conduite comme quand elles sont
délivrées par les murs par les mères à
notre départ voyez donc la chine indice
qui est l'âge pourrait vous les montrer
monsieur si je vous dis c'est que ces
données sur des installations sur des
airs et sur les d aménager et non
aménagés parce qu'il ya des fois aussi
des départements qui n'ont pas tardé de
grand passage
si je voulais être ta cas je vous dirais
que l'on pourra aussi trouver des
agriculteurs qui seraient prêts à vous
faire des attestations de mauvaise
conduite
donc c'est oui c'est pas je pense pas
que je pense pas nous pas sur ce terrain
là qui file sous laon la cmc c'est pas
responsable c'est de larmes c'est la
réponse est hélas on sépare le monde y
pense que c'est quelque chose de plus le
bal dans le monde du voyage et toute une
diversité il ya aussi des gens du voyage
qui savent pas se tenir en en est
conscient mais il faut pas faire une
généralité faut pas mettre tout le monde
dans le même sac
avant tout on est des citoyens nous
sommes des responsables nous comment on
a un mode de vie qui est le voyage on
vit en caravane on
depuis toujours d'ailleurs nos parents
mais avec des caravanes à chaud
mettons-nous avec des caravanes qui sont
peu plus moderne parfaitement aménagés
mais on a besoin d'un certain confort
aussi donc on veut des terrains qui sont
le plat praticable avec l'électricité et
tout ça c'est au frais à la charge des
familles c'est à dire que vous payez
votre consommation en eau en électricité
j'ai toussé comme et assyriens là j'ai
fait un courrier dans toutes les
préfectures de france derrière votre ce
que votre peau structure l'avait reçue
chez pathé mandat les gens que je viens
en région parisienne parce que je suis
plutôt des régions rhône-alpes dessus de
ses dirigeants que l'on fait mais on est
accueilli bien souvent même à bras
ouverts si je vous dis annonce par
certaines communes mais c'est vrai qu'il
n'ya pas de terrain prévues à cet effet
on se met où on se paie ou et le préfet
ne peut pas ordonner des évacuations
c'est bien la problématique s'il n'y a
pas d'air dédié à l'accueil des grands
projets le préfet prendra pas
d'expulsion
henri braun je viens d'accord avec vous
dans ce cas là il faut absolument
trouver une solution ce camp bonnement
vous veniez à cause de lui proposer une
solution puisque vous connaissez bien le
terrain plutôt que de dire que l'on
préfère qu'est ce qui vous empêche rêve
ou d'appuyer le préfet de faire une
suggestion au préfet et de lui dire on a
un terrain des endroits qui seraient
bien on l'a fait on a fait ce travail
sur le sur le du sud yvelines et on
n'est pas arrivé à dégager une solution
et puis vous savez aussi bien que moi
que ça c'est un problème extrêmement
complexe ce renvoi les différents
territoires voisins
je vous invite à prendre la carte du sud
yvelines à partir de versailles et
regarder tout le sud yvelines
il fait nous dans ce cas là des
propositions vous avez deux avocats
henri braun juste avant de conclure
cette émission vous qu'il y avait
une vision un peu plus globale sur les
différentes miquel vous semble être la
solution est ce que sur d'autres
territoires ya des des consensus qui ont
été atteints de la solution je pense et
déjà qu'ils aient suffisamment de places
de stationnement tous les titres de
circulation ont été supprimés mais il
n'empêche que ça donne une idée calmes
du nombre de voyageurs en france on a
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes qui voyagent donc il faut que
chacune de ces personnes de ces
caravanes puisse trouver une place et à
partir du moment où il y aura cette
place pour tout le monde
eh bien il n'y aura plus d'occupation
chez des particuliers dans des stades ou
autre la solution est là et pas ailleurs
et c'est pas c'est une question de bonne
volonté politique les coups ne sont pas
très importants parce que malgré tout
alors un point sur les cookies ses
portes les coûts l'état quand l'ours est
à partager entre les tables qui était
local tata partage entre les deux comme
le dit bruno de laage les familles
payent leur consommation un fluide
parfois des tarifs très élevés dans
certaines aires d'accueil est quelque
chose de très important parce que enfin
que l'on vient on vient d'accueillir
après trente cinq mille réfugiés
politiques
on a trouvé des solutions pour but
c'était très bien parce que c'est des
êtres humains ils méritent le respect
quand nous c'est un problème qui existe
depuis toujours la loi était de mes 90
modifié juillet 2000 et la nouvelle loi
qui est sorti loi égalité citoyenneté on
vous demande juste de trouver des
solutions proposées la curie ce
parallèle avec les réfugiés je pense
qu'il est pas pertinent et j'ai décidé
de mon père mais humblement ne pas le
faire c'est quand même une volée de
l'alena taille quand même une réalité
on attend n'a que et puis c'est bien d
avoir accueilli mais non mais attendez
mais nous ce qu'on a des problèmes de
stationnement parce que nous c'est des
familles que nous avons des femmes des
enfants des personnes âgées et on se
sent pratiquement discriminer voir des
procédures d'expulsion faut toujours
réagir parce que la région nos enfants
on peut parler au travail et on est des
citoyens français monsieur
parfaitement la problématique et je
voulais dit on est de bonne volonté mais
entre des personnes qui subissent la
guerre la misère qui sont 35 milles et
qu'on essaye d'accueillir et pas dans
des conditions toujours toujours très
acceptable et des citoyens français qui
sont simplement dans un mode de vie
auquel devant lequel nous devons trouver
des solutions et c'était le but de la
loi besson pour lesquels n'y a pas de
précarité économique supérieure à
l'ensemble
au reste de la population ou de
certaines d'autres populations on peut
pas comparer les deux et d'ailleurs je
pense que tout amalgame doit vraiment
être être bannis beaucoup de personnes
aussi font l'amalgamé entre les gens du
voyage les roms et les réfugiés ou quand
vous faisiez le parallèle tout à l'heure
avec les sdf en disant que les caravanes
pouvait être une solution au mal
logement en france désolé les sdf s'est
pas uniquement un problème de mal
logement je vous invite honnêtement à ne
pas utiliser ce genre d'argument parce
que vous allez braquer j'aime les gens
qui sont tout à fait réceptif à votre
semblait massé et je pense que c'est
extrêmement dense mais sans conclure
monsieur laitier après vous conclurez je
compte je conclus avec cette
recommandation je le leur pelle non
c'est pas donné mais j'ai l'âge 37 me
faire plaisir on demande juste mon
client ce que vous m'avez vu demander
juste l'application de la loi la
solution la loi égalité sim prévient
déjà fait manquer je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous dans la question
n'est pas parce d'assurer la loi la
saison comment et j'ai alors qu'un je
pense même que d'après ce que j'ai cru
comprendre dans votre département par
rapport à la circulation
10 gens du voyage entre guillemets parce
qu'on veut plus avoir cette appellation
là parce que l'appellation de la danse
un certain fateh supprimé par la loi
d'égalité citoyenneté on se doit de bien
des citoyens était une erreur
voyez donc ça va tellement bien qu'on
ait cette appellation d'un personnage
conclusion arrive en avant conclusion
effectivement il faut appliquer la loi
et bien comprendre que les voyageurs
appartiennent à la collectivité
nationale et qu'ils doivent avoir les
mêmes droits et les mêmes devoirs que
les autres tout simplement un et je
pense que il faut
il faut sortir de cette crispation et
discuter pour trouver des solutions et
ses solutions on peut les trouver
parce qu'on me fera pas croire que dans
le département des yvelines on ne peut
pas trouver quatre hectares pour faire
venir de grands passages absolument les
discussions vont continuer donc voila
merci à tous d'avoir participé à cette
émission on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau débat
[Musique]